- So, is it true,
I found this out, that Margot Robbie,
she tattoos people on set.
- She does.
- She tattoos the people she works with.
Did you let her tattoo your body?
- I plan to.
- Okay, that's a no!
That's a no.
(laughing)
- I plan to.
- I have the intentions.
- I have an appointment,
I think it's around Thursday.
- Well, here's the thing.
No, here's the thing.
In fairness, we talked
about this recently,
and she said I have to
come up with a tattoo
that is very simple and
maybe we put it on a place
that is hidden, just in
case she messes it up.
- That is not who I
want tattooing my body.
(laughing)
Somebody that leads with,
"Just in case I mess this up,
"we should hide it."
- [Jurnee] We should hide it.
- I have like 15 tattoos, so you can get,
yeah, they're hidden.
They're like, a lot of them are hidden.
- Oh, okay.
- They're very addictive.
- I don't have any tattoos.
- Well, you will once you start.
It's very addictive.
- [Jurnee] It's addictive.
- But it's kinda cool to
get a tattoo from her.
Maybe it's like your, you know,
initials of somebody or something.
- Yeah I was thinking
maybe my son or something.
- Yeah, that'd be cool.
You're always gonna love him.
Maybe stick with that one.
- That's the one person in my
life I'm always gonna love.
(laughing)
- Yeah, that's awesome.
- It's like, I always feel
sorry for those people
that get divorced, and it's like on them.
Like, well it's there forever.